В ефірі «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Доброго вечора, вітаю вас!
Вдячні, що ви дивитесь нас.
Пізніше Норберт Леман
розповість про новини спорту.
А зараз теми випуску:
Зменшити тягар поточних обставин -
на літній прес-конференції канцлер пообіцяв
державну допомогу людям,
які, як він заявив,
«мають дуже мало».
Докази удару по Криму -
вибухами було знищено щонайменше
сім російських літаків.
Раніше Росія це заперечувала.
Майже без води під Кілем -
Через посуху транспортування
сировини Рейном практично зупинилося,
що створило нову загрозу економіці.
«Ми переживаємо серйозні часи,
які багато потребуватимуть від нас», -
заявив сьогодні Олаф Шольц на своїй
першій літній пресконференції
на посаді канцлера.
Він пообіцяв нове
послаблення енергетичного тягаря,
і, що ніхто не буде один на
своєму шляху.
Тож, хвилюватися не варто.
З Берліна повідомляє
Брітта Шпікерман.
Проблеми здаються величезними:
Війна в Україні, газова криза,
до того ж коронавірус.
Шольц поводиться розслаблено,
демонструє, що все під контролем.
Його основне твердження:
«Ви ніколи не будете одні на своєму шляху».
Ніхто не залишиться на самоті.
Я переймаюся за тих,
хто має дуже мало.
Ось чому ми повідомили,
що плануємо внести зміни в
дотації на оплату житла
та мито на право громадянства.
Ці реформи зараз активно готуються.
Шольц розповідає про
багатомільярдні пакети допомоги.
Вони вже формуються,
і вже у вересні населення
побачить їх у свої платіжках.
Соціальний спокій буде збережено.
Соціальна держава дбатиме про
добробут, хвилюватися не варто.
Я хочу чітко донести
свою повну впевненість у тому,
що ми впораємось.
Це буде нашою німецькою відповіддю
не посталі виклики.
Не повинно бути
«податку на надприбуток»
стосовно енергетичних компаній.
Так само жодного підвищення
максимальної податкової ставки.
Ми домовилися не підвищувати
податок на прибуток для компаній,
які отримають значну виручку.
Про це зазначалося у
передвиборчій програмі СДПН,
а також у Зелених,
але не третьої партії коаліції.
Запитали також і про
фінансовий скандал «CumEx Files»,
пов'язаний з банком
«Hamburger Warburg».
У той час Шольц був
бургомістром Гамбурга.
Навіть сьогодні він
заперечує будь-яку участь
та відкидає наявність
контактів з аферистами.
За два з половиною роки
пройшло вже безліч слухань,
але судові справи призвели
лише до одного результату:
Немає жодних доказів того,
що там був політичний вплив.
Під час обговорення війни
в Україні Шольц підкреслив,
що Німеччина в жодному разі
не відмовляється постачати зброю,
і його уряд продовжить
підтримувати Україну.
Що має статися зараз,
це наше головне завдання:
аби Росія усвідомила, що вона
має запровадити перемир'я з Україною,
і це не може бути нав’язаний мир.
З короновірусом все так добре,
що і говорити нема про що.
У вересні Бундестаг
має прийняти новий закон.
Це дає надію на те,
що існуючі суперечності щодо
обмежувальних заходів будуть вирішені.
Шакунтала Банерджі в Берліні.
Той, хто слухав канцлера може
подумати, що у влади все під контролем.
Так, про самокритику не йшлося,
радше про самоствердження.
Канцлер скористався нагодою,
щоб подати сигнал:
«Я дотримуюся курсу, як щодо змісту,
так і щодо стилю правління».
Цей сигнал особливо цікавий,
оскільки його коаліція вже тріщить по швах.
Тут в Берліні відчутна напруга
між партіями ВДП і Зеленими.
І не лише щодо податкової політики та
продовження експлуатації атомних електростанцій.
Можна було очікувати,
що вирішальне слово скаже канцлер.
Він цього не зробив і дав зрозуміти,
що це - не його стиль.
Він продовжує покладатися
на коаліційну угоду,
і ще раз дав це зрозуміти.
Канцлер впевнений, що її вистачить
на наступні десять років.
Великих сюрпризів не було.
Це був типовий Шольц, тож
не варто було очікувати на зміну стилю.
Ви почули коментар Шакунтали Банерджі
Дуже дякую!
Оскільки Росія
скоротила постачання газу,
енергетичні компанії змушені купувати
енергоносії в інших місцях за вищими цінами,
З жовтня уряд дозволить їм перекладати
свої високі витрати на споживачів газу,
яких своєю чергою буде
субсидіювати федеральний уряд.
Газопостачальна компанія «RWE» оголосила,
що не буде користуватися цим правом.
Що за цим стоїть?
Френк Бетман.
Першою причиною стали
великі прибутки «RWE».
За перше півріччя без сплати відсотків
і податків вони склали 2,8 мільярдів євро.
Рекордний показник.
Компанія отримує вигоду
від енергетичної кризи,
а точніше від росту цін на енергоносії.
Перш за все від відновлювальних джерел,
тобто експлуатацію вітрових
та сонячних електростанцій.
Несподівано високі прибутки
практично впали «RWE» з неба.
Компанія, як інші компанії
з виробництва відновлювальної енергії,
може постачати дешевшу електроенергію,
аніж виробляють газові електростанції.
Однак їй дозволено стягувати плату
за дешеву електроенергію
за різко завищеними цінами
цих газових електростанцій.
Звучить парадоксально,
але це збільшує прибуток.
і, своєю чергою, викликає запитання:
Хіба держава не має втрутитися?
Впровадити податок на надприбуток?
Поки що представники «RWE»
не заглиблювалися у це питання.
Компанія планує інвестувати
отриманий прибуток
в перехід до відновлювальних джерел.
Вона відмовилась
підвищувати ціну на газ,
втім це не скасовує питання
надприбутку з порядку денного.
Дякую, Френк Бетман з Франкфурта.
Погляньмо на ситуацію в Україні.
Президент Зеленський
неодноразово обіцяв своєму народу,
що Крим буде відвойовано.
Нові супутникові знімки
показали наслідки
атаки на російську військову базу
на окупованому півострові.
Москва визнала,
що там сталися вибухи
проте повідомляє
про нещасний випадок.
Репортаж Пабло Силалахі.
Супутникові знімки
американської компанії
показують ступінь ураження об’єкту.
На окупованому
росіянами аеродромі «Саки»
було знищено
щонайменше сім бойових літаків.
Проте як так сталося, що в тилу
окупованого Криму пролунали вибухи,
достеменно невідомо.
Як і невідомо те, хто це зробив.
Москва применшує розгром
і заперечує знищення авіації.
Вони заявляють
про детонацію боєприпасів,
які підпалив необачний палій.
Малоймовірно,
що це був вибух боєприпасів
через недотримання пожежної безпеки.
Усе вказує на те,
що це була операція
українських Збройних сил.
Визнання цього зруйнувало б
два міфи російського керівництва:
Про ефективність
російських Збройних сил
та протиповітряної оборони Криму,
яка не спрацювала.
І по-друге,
це була обмежена військова операція,
яка не уразила населення
на окупованій Росією території,
але вплинула на російське населення.
Також вибухи було чутно
сьогодні в Донецькій області.
У Донецьку зайнявся пивоварний завод
і стався витік аміаку.
Повідомляється також
про бої біля Бахмута на Сході
і біля Нікополя на Півдні.
По цьому місту
було випущено 120 ракет.
Нікополь розташований
за 80 км від Запоріжжя.
У цій області знаходиться найбільша
атомна електростанція Європи.
Її обстрілюють вже
впродовж декількох днів.
Президент Зеленський
попереджає про новий Чорнобиль.
Роками ніхто не вірив,
що Європа знову опиниться
під загрозою нової катастрофи,
і не тому,
що хтось порушує заходи безпеки.
Роками нікому не спадало на думку,
що атомну електростанцію
використають для терору.
Як це зараз робить Росія.
Небезпекою ядерної катастрофи
сьогодні зайнята
Рада безпеки ООН у Нью-Йорку.
Там проводять екстрену нараду.
Анна Брюль з Запоріжжя,
що за 60 км від атомної електростанції,
Анно, наскільки небезпечною
виглядяє ситуація насправді?
Ситуація дуже тривожна.
Сьогодні пообіді
пролунало кілька вибухів
на території ЗАЕС.
Український «Енегроатом»
заявляє про чотири.
Там заявили про пошкодження
будівлі біля енергоблоку.
Також були пошкоджені
датчики випромінювання.
Це погана звістка.
Ми самі були сьогодні в Нікополі,
за 4 км від ЗАЕС.
Нікополь постійно обстрілюють,
як про це вже казали раніше.
Проте людей сильно
непокоїть загроза ядерної катастрофи
у безпосередній близькості від міста.
У місті роздають таблетки йоду,
також є плани евакуації,
оскільки на території цієї АЕС
може статися велика аварія.
Не лише жителі Нікополя
у великій небезпеці.
Дякую за інформацію.
Анна Брюль з Запоріжжя.
Наскільки ядерна небезпека
загрожує Німеччині?
Які заходи вживаються у
випадку надзвичайної ситуації?
Дивіться у нашому додатку «ZDFheute»:
відповіді на найважливіші питання від
експерта з радіаційної безпеки.
Посушливе літо в Німеччині
стає все більшою проблемою.
Висихають озера та річки.
Рівень води в Рейні та багатьох
інших водоймах падає.
Завтра рівень води
біля міста Кауб знизиться
нижче позначки в 40 сантиметрів,
ця тенденція збережеться.
Попередній рекорд:
25 см у посушливий 2018 рік.
Ідеться про транспортування сировини.
Попри ширину фарватера,
глибини каналу під Кілем
вже недостатньо для багатьох суден.
Анзельм Штерн.
На могутньому Рейні сліди посухи.
Бінген, Рейнланд-Пфальц:
тут річка значною мірою
перетворилася на кам’яне поле.
В ній замало води, відтак
водна артерія мілкішає і вужчає.
Вантажні судна курсують,
але практично не завантажені.
Виконується значно менший обсяг перевезень.
У порівнянні з нормальним рівнем води,
зараз ми завантажуємо кораблі
приблизно наполовину
від максимальної вантажності.
Половину або менше,
більше вже не можна.
Рейн вже недостатньо глибокий,
а це означає набагато менше перевезених
хімікатів, палива, вугілля
надходить на підприємства,
і це зараз, коли попит на те ж вугілля,
різко зростає
через війну з Росією.
Це вже призводить до зростання цін та занепокоєння..
Якщо ситуація погіршиться,
ціни на транспортування зростуть ще більше.
Наразі ми вже спостерігаємо підвищення цін
через низький рівень води,
тому що судна, що курсують країною,
не можуть взяти на себе багато вантажу
і змушені здійснювати рейси частіше.
Нам потрібно більше транспорту.
Наприклад, АЗС доведеться, ймовірно,
відмовитися від мінеральних мастил,
які доставляються внутрішніми водними шляхами,
а нашим компаніям - від сировини,
яка їм конче необхідна.
Ця тема особливо актуальна зараз,
наприклад, тут, у Каубі, неподалік Бінгена.
Це критично важливе вузьке місце на Рейні.
Одна з найважливіших водних артерій Європи
із кожним днем втрачає свою силу.
Крістель Гаас стоїть у руслі Рейну біля Бінгена.
І взагалі дивує, що великі кораблі
досі можуть плавати тут.
Крістель?
Зазвичай вода в цьому місці доходила б мені
до голови чи вище..
Тепер тут лише галька.
Кораблі проходять фарватером,
всі стежать за рівнем води.
Кожен судноплавець повинен вирішити для себе,
чи може він пройти руслом чи ні.
Щодня.
Чим нижчий рівень води, тим менше кораблів
можуть це зробити.
На питання, чи можна організувати перевезення
автомобільним
чи залізничним транспортом,
компанії відповідають - «ні».
Бракує водіїв вантажівок, залізниця не має
достатніх потужностей.
Тож занепокоєння триває.
Дякую Крістель Гаас у Бінгені.
Посуха завдає величезних збитків по всій Європі.
Лісові пожежі - це економічна та екологічна трагедія.
Наприклад, у Португалії: у центрі країни,
в одному з найбільших природних парків,
спалахнуло одразу кілька пожеж.
Наразі вогонь особливо лютує на
південному заході Франції.
Знову поблизу Бордо, де нещодавно, у липні,
була сильна пожежа.
Анна Варсберг.
Полум'я повернулося і продовжує прокладати собі
шлях через ліс.
Знову тут, у Жиронді на південному заході Франції.
Знову люди мусять поспіхом
залишати свої будинки.
Перед дітьми ми вдаємо, що не хвилюємося.
Але, звичайно, ми дуже стурбовані.
Ми не знаємо, коли зможемо повернутись.
Лісові пожежі у липні були під контролем.
Тепер вогонь спалахнув з новою силою.
Рятувальні служби
ведуть цілодобову боротьбу з полум'ям
у восьми місцях у Франції.
Після заклику про допомогу з боку уряду
з усієї Європи прибула підмога.
Європейська комісія оголосила,
що вона також мобілізує літаки -
сили для підтримки Франції.
Також будуть мобілізовані рятувальні служби
з Німеччини, Польщі,
Австрії та Румунії.
У Португалії також постійно виникають
нові лісові пожежі.
У природному парку Серра-да-Ештрела вже вигоріло
понад 10 тисяч гектарів.
Саме через поєднання вітру, посухи та спеки
пожежі на південному заході Європи
розповсюджуються так швидко та масштабно.
Наразі з'ясовується, чи відіграє роль підпал і де саме.
І в іншому місці стають очевидними руйнівні
наслідки спеки:
льодовики Альп тануть з рекордною швидкістю.
Експерти попереджають, що з п'яти льодовиків,
що залишилися в Німеччині,
один може зникнути вже цього року -
Південний Шнеєфернер на Цугшпітце.
Окрім температури, це пов'язано
із весняним пилом Сахари:
він поглинає набагато більше тепла, ніж поверхня
льоду чи снігу.
А зараз про смерть 16-річного підлітка,
що викликає багато запитань.
У понеділок поліцейський у Дортмунді
вистрілив із автоматичної зброї в обличчя, живіт,
руку та плече ﻿молодого сенегальця.
Сьогодні міністр внутрішніх справ Ройль пообіцяв
стовідсоткове роз'яснення
і водночас застеріг від упереджених думок.
Подробиці у Гайка Рамса.
Дортмунд-Нордштадт вчора ввечері.
Другий день поспіль
люди проводять демонстрації проти ймовірного
насильства з боку поліції.
Протести були викликані смертю біженця.
У нього влучило п'ять поліцейських куль
після того, як він, ймовірно, напав на офіцерів з ножем.
До цього, як то повідомляють,
юнак погрожував самогубством.
Спроба розмови між поліцейськими та хлопчиком
провалилася,
за словами міністра внутрішніх справ
Північного Рейна-Вестфалії.
Потім спробували знешкодити його за допомогою
газового балончика.
Після чого поліцейські спробували стримати його
за допомогою електрошокерів,
а також знерухомити.
Ситуація стала загрозливою,
і тоді поліцейський, який відповідав за неї,
здійснив постріли з відстані.
Юнак згодом помер у лікарні.
Ще напередодні він проходив лікування в клініці
через психологічні проблеми.
Підлітку протистояло одинадцятеро поліцейських.
Невідомо, чи розумів біженець із Сенегалу
німецьку мову достатньою мірою.
Але це також означає, що я маю відступити
як офіцер поліції
та спробувати переоцінити ситуацію.
Тільки в разі дійсно серйозної небезпеки,
коли конкретний напад є неминучим,
я можу скористатися вогнепальною зброєю.
І тут у мене виникають сумніви.
Необхідно також уточнити,
чому використали саме автоматичну зброю.
Прокуратура Дортмунда розпочала розслідування.
Марбурзька профспілка занепокоєна з приводу
трудового навантаження в німецьких лікарнях.
Згідно з опитуванням,
проведеним членами організації,
чверть працюючих лікарів
розмірковують про звільнення з професії.
Одна з основних причин - велика кількість
понаднормових годин роботи.
57% опитаних заявили,
що працюють по 49 і більше годин на тиждень.
До того ж лікарі скаржаться, зокрема, на те,
що багато часу йде на адміністративну роботу.
Ще один серйозний нещасний випадок у парку розваг:
у Леголенді під Гюнцбургом понад 30 людей
зазнали травм,
двоє з них - важких.
Представник поліції пояснив,
що вагончик американських гірок
різко загальмував біля входу,
і наступний врізався в нього.
Досі незрозуміло, як це могло статися.
Лише на минулих вихідних в Клоттені,
Рейнланд-Пфальц,
жінка впала з американських гірок і загинула.
А тепер до новин футболу, Норберте.
Учора «Айнтрахт» не зміг показати себе у матчі
з мадридським «Реалом»
у Суперкубку УЄФА.
Королівська команда була франкфуртцям не по зубах -
0:2 проти переможця Ліги чемпіонів.
Але ці емоції відрізнялися від поразки 1:6
проти «Баварії» минулої п'ятниці.
Цього разу - поразка з гордо піднятою головою.
Оплески переможеному.
Легендарний «Реал Мадрид»
виструнчився перед «Айнтрахтом».
На 37-й хвилині Давид Алаба виводить «Реал» уперед.
У другому таймі вирішується результат матчу,
коли захист франкфуртців не атакує Бензема,
а блокує огляд Кевіну Траппу.
Це тренувальний матч для «Айнтрахту»
перед Лігою чемпіонів.
Тому ми бачили, що цього замало для такого рівня,
для такого суперника.
Мадридський «Реал» завоював
свій 28-й міжнародний титул у Гельсінкі.
Розпочався перший день змагань і на чемпіонаті
Європи у Мюнхені,
Чемпіонаті Європи з дев'яти видів спорту,
включно з веслуванням.
І там місцевий герой та чинний чемпіон Олівер Зайдлер
після перших труднощів вийшов до півфіналу
в одиночному розряді.
На фініші Олівер Зайдлер був трохи розчарований.
Тому що на старті, коли він розпочав гонку другим,
він мав багато проблем, не мав тиску на лопатку весла,
він втратив багато секунд на користь суперників.
Але Зайдлер наздогнав їх і на фініші був явно попереду.
У суботу він змагатиметься у півфіналі,
а у чоловіча вісімка - вже у фіналі.
Друга за швидкістю у попередньому запливі,
німецька команда вийшла до фіналу.
Британці сьогодні знову не перемогли.
Жіноча збірна Німеччини зі спортивної гімнастики
також вийшла у командний фінал у суботу,
хоча Сара Фосс зазнала невдачі на колоді,
але змогла продовжити виступ.
На брусах Елізабет Зайц та Кім Буї були
практично бездоганними
і тому мають найкращі шанси
здобути медалі в одиночному фіналі.
Результати змагань у одиночному багатоборстві
можна побачити у прямому ефірі на сайті sportstudio.de
Тугу за свіжим бризом нині відчувають
на вітрильній виставці «Hanse Sail» у Ростоку,
де можна побачити не лише безліч традиційних суден.
Ті, хто добре витримує морські прогулянки,
можуть підняти вітрила і вирушити в подорож.
Але й решта знайдуть собі розвагу
на цьому міксі фестивалю та культурної програми.
Тут немає жодних обмежень, жодних тестів чи масок,
лише багато здорового морського повітря.
Спекотна літня погода також має свої позитивні сторони,
наприклад, зорепади.
Катя Хорнефер незабаром покаже вам їх.
Марієтта Сломка вітає вас у «heute journal» о 22:10.
А ми з вами побачимось завтра.
Гарного вечора і усього найкращого!
До побачення!
Добрий вечір!
Дивіться, зірка падає!
Одна зі 100 за годину, які можна побачити вночі.
Вона викликана кометою Свіфта-Туттля,
яку було відкритою 160 років тому.
Вона проноситься навколо Сонця
і втрачає дрібні частинки пилу та каміння.
Кожного серпня Земля перетинає цю хмару
космічних частинок
на своїй орбіті.
Коли ці частинки потрапляють до нашої атмосфери,
вони починають світитися.
Якщо дивитися із Землі,
це відбувається поблизу сузір'я Персея.
Саме тому ці зорепади називають Персеїдами.
Пік зорепадів, ймовірно,
припаде на суботу о 3 годині ранку.
Тут буде досить безхмарно.
Однак місячне сяйво може завадити,
бо завтра вранці о 3.34 ранку буде повний місяць.
До ранку температура опуститься до 18 градусів на Рейні
та до 10 градусів на околиці Альп.
Завтра також буде дуже сонячно.
У другій половині дня у Східній Баварії
можливі невеликі грози.
Температура сягатиме від 23 до 34 градусів тепла,
а вихідні дні будуть сонячними та спекотними.
Але до понеділка вітер зміниться на південно-західний,
і буде задуха та грози.
Гарного вечора!